bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du télescope spatial james webb je suis
sûr que vous avez tous vu passer les
magnifiques images qui ont été révélées
mi juillet à l'issue des six premiers
mois de fonctionnement du télescope mais
outre ces images les équipes en charge
du télescope ont également publié un
gros article scientifique d'une
cinquantaine de pages afin de faire le
bilan du fonctionnement de la bête suite
à cette période de mise en service j'ai
eu l'occasion de lire l'article et
aujourd'hui je vais donc vous raconter
le fonctionnement du télescope est ce
que les scientifiques en dise à l'issue
de ce rodage est clairement ce qui en
ressort c'est que pour l'instant le
télescope james webb fonctionne quasi
parfaitement et dépasse même les
attentes des scientifiques sur ses
performances
avant de rentrer dans le vif du sujet
essayons déjà de comprendre quels sont
les objectifs scientifiques de ce
télescope dans quel but at il été conçu
tout d'abord un point clé il s'agit d'un
télescope qui observe l'infrarouge vous
avez sans doute que le spectre des ondes
électromagnétiques est composé de
différentes familles suivant la longueur
d'onde ça va des rayons gamma aux ondes
radio en passant par le visible
l'infrarouge ou encore les micro ondes
et toutes ces longueurs d'onde peuvent
être utilisés pour faire de l'astronomie
pour regarder le ciel on peut observer
aussi bien la lumière visible que les
rayons x l'infrarouge où les ondes radio
simplement on ne peut pas utiliser le
même appareil pour tous un télescope est
conçu pour fonctionner dans une
certaines plages de longueur d'onde le
télescope spatial hubble fonctionne
entre 200 nanomètres et 2.4 micron
c'est-à-dire l'ultraviolet le visible et
le proche infrarouge le télescope james
webb lui est conçu pour opérer entre 600
nanomètres et 28 micron 6 100 nanomètres
ça veut dire qu'ils voient le rouge et
l'orangé mais pas vraiment les autres
couleurs visibles en particulier
contrairement à apple ils ne voient pas
le bleu et encore moins les uv donc
quand vous voyez une image comme celle
ci ça n'est pas littéralement ce que
voit le télescope ce sont des fausses
couleurs en l'occurrence ici le bleu
représente des longueurs d'onde autour
de 9 100 nanomètres cdu proche
infrarouge
alors pourquoi observé l'infrarouge
c'est quoi l'intérêt scientifique
pourquoi ne pas avoir choisi la même
plage que hubble par exemple eh bien il
y a plusieurs objectifs tout d'abord
observer des galaxies très lointaine
vous le savez peut-être plus une galaxie
est lointaine plus elle nous apparaît
rouge à cause de l'expansion de
l'univers qui cause un décalage vers le
rouge et en fait même certaines sont
carrément dans l'infrarouge hubble était
capable de voir des galaxies datant
d'environ 500 millions d'années après le
big bang et leur longueur d'onde était
tellement décalé vers le rouge qu'elle
était multipliée par dix on appelle ce
facteur le redshift un souvent noté z et
hubble a pu voir des galaxy jusqu'à même
des dégâts le 11 le télescope james webb
lui devrait être capable d'observer des
décalages jusqu'à z et galvin pour des
galaxies datant de seulement 150
millions d'années après le big bang mais
c'est légal 20 ça veut dire la chose
suivante prenez une étoile comme le
soleil qui aimait tout un spectre de
longueur d'onde dont le pic est autour
de 5 100 nanomètres en plein dans la
lumière visible donc et bien avec z et
galvin une étoile comme le soleil nous
apparaît très décalé avec un pic plutôt
à 10 microns complètement dans
l'infrarouge et impossible à observer en
lumière visible évidemment à une telle
distance on va pas observé des étoiles
individuel 1 plutôt des galaxies
entières mais vous voyez l'idée
d'observer dans l'infrarouge on pourra
mieux détecter ces galaxies lointaines
et très ancien et donc mieux comprendre
comment les premières galaxies se sont
formées après le big bang autre intérêt
de l'infrarouge il traverse beaucoup
mieux les nuages de poussière plus la
longueur d'onde est grande moins la
lumière est affecté par la diffusion sur
des petites particules ça se voit très
bien sur l'image que j'ai déjà montré la
nébuleuse de la carène quand on compare
humble et le james webb non seulement
avec james webb la résolution est
meilleur mais en plus on voit des choses
qui se passent derrière en arrière-plan
et qui avec hubble n'était pas détectés
car la lumière visible et plus
facilement bloquée par la poussière en
infrarouge ça permet de voir à travers
les nuages de poussière qui se trouve
dans l'espace et donc d'avoir accès à
des phénomènes nouveaux en particulier
concernant la naissance des étoiles et
l'évolution des galaxies et puis dernier
intérêt de l'infrarouge c'est d'observer
des exoplanètes si on prend une planètes
comme la terre elle est à 15 degrés
environ en moyenne donc son rayonnement
naturel celui qu'on appelle le
rayonnement du corps noir qui résulte de
sa température est distribué autour de
10 donc l'infrarouge et très adaptée à
la recherche d'exoplanètes ayant une
température proche de la nôtre en
particulier pour espérer trouver des
traces de vie extraterrestre on aimerait
pouvoir estimer la composition de
certaines planètes à partir des
longueurs d'onde absorbés par leur
atmosphère dans l'infrarouge avec la
plage d'observation du james webb voici
à quoi ressemblerait le spectre en
transmission de la terre dans
l'infrarouge tous les creux
correspondent à des longueurs d'onde
absorbé par certaines molécules l'eau le
méthane l'ozone etc et nous renseigne
donc sur la composition de l'atmosphère
au total en raison de ces différents
objectifs scientifiques l'infrarouge et
ben c'est super la difficulté en temps
normal c'est que comme on vient de le
dire l'atmosphère de la terre absorbe
beaucoup d'infrarouge donc c'est une
plage de longueur d'onde pas facile à
observer avec un télescope basés au sol
d'où l'intérêt d'aller dans l'espace
voilà pour les objectifs scientifique du
télescope passons maintenant à la
mission elle-même vous vous en souvenez
peut-être le lancement a lieu le 25
décembre 2021 depuis la base de kourou
en guyane à bord d'une fusée ariane 5 le
lancement a été un très gros succès et
ça n'est pas rien parce qu'on parle
quand même d'un bébé qui est développé
depuis plus de vingt ans et qui aura
coûté 10 milliards de dollars dont qu'il
y avait un peu de pression au décollage
concernant la localisation du télescope
il faut bien comprendre qu'on est sur
quelque chose de très très différent du
télescope hubble c'est même assez
difficile de comparer un même les
schémas fournis par la nasa sont pas à
l'échelle mais bon essayons quand même
la terre fait environ 12 mille sept cent
kilomètres de diamètre
la station spatiale internationale
orbite à 400 mètres d'altitude donc en
fait très très proche de la surface bun
lui se trouve à 540 kilomètres
d'altitude juste un peu au dessus la
lune se trouve à 380 mille kilomètres
donc 700 fois plus loin que hubble ce
que je désigne pour qu'on la voit et on
voit plus du tout leurs beats du
télescope hubble hélas si je garde les
tailles de la terre et de la lune à
l'échelle on voit pas grand chose à nos
jours et les agrandir artificiellement
bien et maintenant le james webb eh ben
ils se trouvent à 1,5 million de km de
la terre et je dois encore dézoomer pour
qu'on s'en rende compte et en fait
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
il n'est pas en orbite autour de la
terre mais plutôt autour du soleil mais
en un point très spécial qu'on appelle
le point de lagrange l2 les ce point en
particulier de l'espace c'est de faire
en sorte que le télescope spatial tourne
autour du soleil mais au même rythme que
la terre pour pas qu'ils se trouve d'un
côté du soleil quand nous on est de
l'autre par exemple le souci c'est que
normalement plus un objet se trouve
éloignée du soleil plus sa période de
révolution est lente par exemple avec
les planètes ainsi nous fait le tour en
un an venus qui est plus proche fait le
tour du soleil en seulement huit mois et
mars plus lointaines en presque deux ans
donc si on met le télescope quelque part
dit long entre la terre et mars eh bien
il va tourner trop lentement pour rester
synchro avec la terre sauf qu'il existe
quelques endroits très particulier qui
sont telles que l'attraction combiné de
la terre et du soleil fait en sorte que
la période soit synchrone avec celle de
la terre ces points s'appelle les points
de lagrange et il y en a justement un
dans l'axé soleil-terre à 1,5 million de
kilomètres c'est le point d'y l2 et
c'est un endroit de choix pour ce genre
de satellites on y trouve d'ailleurs
aussi le satellite planck lancé en 2009
qui a observé le rayonnement fossile
pour ceux que ça intéresse j'avais fait
un billet de blog il ya fort longtemps
sur les points de lagrange et je vous
mets le lien en descriptions l'intérêt
de ce point l2 c'est que le télescope
aura une position à peu près constante
par rapport à la terre la lune et le
soleil ce qui évitera les changements de
température qui serait compliqué à gérer
le télescope aura toujours le dos au
soleil mais ne sera jamais dans l'ombre
j'ai téléchargé un modèle 3d du
satellite et on voit ici la partie
télescope proprement dit et là un grand
bouclier thermique pour bloquer les
rayons du soleil qui arrive comme ça on
a aussi des panneaux solaires pour
alimenter l'ensemble et fournir une
puissance proche de 2 kilowatts
bon ça c'est pour la logistique mais
puisqu'on est sur le modèle passons
maintenant au coeur la partie télescope
proprement dit la caractéristique
reconnaissable du james webb c'est
évidemment ce grand miroir doré en nid
d'abeille mais dans le dispositif il y a
en réalité trois miroirs consécutif ce
design avec trois miroirs permet de
minimiser certaines aberrations optiques
le deuxième miroir beaucoup plus petit
est là il reçoit les rayons en
provenance du premier et il est fixé sur
cette espèce de structure avec trois
pattes et enfin le troisième miroir et
ben il est là dedans il reçoit la
lumière renvoyé par le deuxième est la
dirigent vers les instruments de mesure
le miroir principal fait six mètres
cinquante de diamètre ça fait une
surface iron quatre fois plus
importantes que le télescope hubble et
ce qui est notable c'est son allure
particulière la raison c'est que lancer
directement un gros miroir de plus de 6
mètres eh ben ça aurait été compliqué
d'où le fait d'utiliser ces 18 miroir
hexagonaux plus petits qui se sont
dépliés une fois le télescope en place
ces miroirs sont recouverts d'une fine
couche d'or ça c'est pour bien réfléchir
le rayonnement infrarouge qui nous
intéresse et chacun est monté sur une
série de micro moteur qui peuvent
permettre de donner à l'ensemble du
miroir la forme adéquate la précision de
ces micro moteur serait inférieur à 100
nanomètres ça veut dire qu'on arrive à
modifier la forme d'un truc qui fait si
m à l'échelle de 100 nanomètres un dix
millième de millimètre c'est quand même
dingue lent dans la phase de mise en
service qui vient de s'achever les
responsables du télescope ont évidemment
voulu tester pour voir s'il répondait
bien aux cahiers des charges est-ce que
du point de vue de l'optique on atteint
les résolutions voulu pour ça on doit
notamment mesuré une quantité qu'on
appelle la psf print sprite function
l'idée c'est qu'avec un télescope même
si vous observez une source super
ponctuelles un point minuscule dans le
ciel et bien il ne fera jamais pile un
point sur les images que vous
récupérerez c'est pas une question de
pixels ça va toujours baver un peu et
faire une sorte de tâche notamment à
cause du phénomène de diffraction la
diffraction limite fondamentalement la
résolution et la psf c'est en gros à
quoi va ressembler sur l'image un truc
qui aurait dû être ponctuel pour quelle
mesure sa base avec le james webb la psf
à une forme un peu particulière ça n'est
pas juste une tâche ronde mais on voit
comme des pics à des angles de 60 degrés
alors c'est parfaitement normal on sait
que ces pics sont dues aux raccords
entre les hexagones du miroir primaire
et à la structure qui tient miroir
secondaire ils apparaissent surtout
quand on a une source très lumineuse
comme sur cette image mais en
contrepartie on sait que la tâche
centrale sera moins et allez donc
c'était un choix assumé dans le design
du télescope la façon dont tout ça
s'étale peut se quantifier il ya un
indicateur et plus et faible mieux c'est
et je vous passe les détails techniques
mais ce qu'on voit sur ce graphique tiré
de l'article c'est qu'à chaque fois les
performances réelles sont meilleurs que
ce qui avait été anticipé donc gros
succès de ce point de vue là bien
maintenant qu'on sait que les miroirs
marche bien passons aux instruments que
l'on met derrière pour obtenir des
images on l'a dit l'idée c'est
d'observer dans l'infrarouge de 6 100
nanomètres jusqu'à 28 micro et pour
faire ça on va utiliser différents types
de capteurs un premier instrument qui
peut sembler accessoires mais qui est
important c'est le fgs fine guidance
system c'est un instrument qui sert
juste aux satellites à repérer les
étoiles environnantes pour pouvoir se
positionner précisément c'est un peu son
gps si vous voulez et ce qui est fou
c'est que rien que les images faites
avec sont déjà super chouette pour un
truc qui n'est pas censé servir à
prendre des photos seins ils marchent
quand même vachement bien et par
ailleurs son efficacité pour le
positionnement est excellente passons
maintenant aux instruments principaux
pour faciliter les choses ils sont
divisés en deux plages d'observation
entre 0 6 et 5 microns le proche
infrarouge et entre 5 et 27 micro plutôt
l'infrarouge moyen pour l'infrarouge
proche il y à l'instrument ni rcam
fournir infrared camair il couvre un
champ angulaire de deux arcs minutes
c'est un trentième de degrés donc
imaginé une fenêtre d'un millimètre
carré situé à deux mètres de vous et
pour faire une photo de ce minuscule
bout de ciel eh bien on a dit capteur de
4 mégapixels et toutes les longueurs
d'onde ne se pas observé de la même
façon dont on utilise différents filtres
qui balaye la plage et à partir de ce
qu'on observe avec chaque filtre on peut
faire des rendus en fausses couleurs
comme celui dont on a parlé au début
un point important de ces appareils
c'est que pour observer correctement le
ciel dans cette gamme de longueurs
d'onde il ne faut pas que l'instrument
lui même soit trop chaud sinon son
propre rayonnement thermique va venir
perturber la mesure pour ça la
température du capteur doit rester en
dessous de 37 kelvin donc pas loin de
moins de 135 degrés celsius et avec ça
acquérir une image va quand même prendre
plusieurs boucles télescope doit bien
sûr se maintenir dans la bonne
orientation pour compenser sa
trajectoire
l'instrument ni rcam permet donc de
faire des images très résolus mais on a
des infos que sur les bandes de longueur
d'onde qui ont été choisis en fonction
des filtres une chose très intéressante
qu'on fait aussi en astronomie c'est de
la spectroscopie c'est-à-dire mesurer
avec précision la composition du spectre
sourds tout une plage de longueur d'onde
j'en avais parlé dans ma vidéo sur les
exoplanètes pour faire ça on utilise un
spectrographe et souvent c'est un
appareil danel ce qu'on met derrière le
télescope pour analyser la lumière de
l'ensemble de l'image donc par exemple
on pointe sur une étoile et on analyse
cette étoile le problème c'est qu'avec
le télescope james webb eh bien on peut
avoir potentiellement tout un tas
d'objets intéressants qui sont
différents et donc on ne veut pas les
analyser ensemble or il se trouve que
l'instrument nirspec permet de faire de
la spectroscopie multi objets on peut
sélectionner les objets d'intérêt sur
une image et grâce à un système de
masques et de micros obturateur nirspec
analysera individuellement les spectres
des différents objets en tout ça c'est
pour la gamme de 0,6 à 5 microns passons
maintenant au delà de 5 microns et
jusqu'à 27 migrants et là c'est encore
plus compliqué cissé de l'infrarouge
plus lointain ça veut dire qu'il faut
refroidir encore plus bas pour éviter
les parasites thermique grâce à un
circuit à hélium liquide recyclé
l'instrument miri airs froide et a6
kelvin seulement - 267 degré et c'est un
instrument qui va faire à la fois caméra
pour faire des images et spectraux pour
avoir les spectres
alors pour être complet ajoutons aussi
l'instrument ni risque qui est couplé au
système de positionnement mgs et qui
permet aussi de faire des spectres mais
sur des grands angles de vue enfin de
rang 1 30e 2° quoi et enfin dernière
précision il y à tous ces instruments à
bord et quand on observe il faut choisir
lequel on utilise mais apparemment il
existe plusieurs manières d'en utiliser
deux à la fois ça peut servir ça c'était
pour la partie vraiment acquisition du
signal maintenant il faut aussi
transmettre tout ça vers la terre on
fait sur place qu'un minimum de
traitement il ya un convertisseur
analogique-numérique qui consomme
seulement 11 milliwatts bail c'est pour
éviter de chauffer comme une grosse
carte graphique et de perturber les
mesures et ensuite tout ça est transmis
vers la terre avec un débit de 28
mégabits par seconde donc c'est pas tout
à fait la fibre alors nous vous qu'est
ce qu'on apprend dans le rapport sur le
fonctionnement de tous ces instruments
et ben ça marche nickel tous les
instruments marche mieux que prévu avec
des sensibilités qui sont souvent
meilleurs que les spécifications visé
donc c'est un peu de champagne quand
même maintenant c'est quoi l'avenir du
télescope et bien il faut quand même
parlé de deux trucs qui sont des défauts
et qui sont discutées dans le rapport
premièrement il existe dans le satellite
un chemin lumineux appelé voyons qui
permet à de la lumière parasite
d'atteindre dire comment le troisième
miroir sans passer par les deux autres
alors c'était anticipé 1 et ça provoque
dans certaines circonstances des défauts
sur les images qui portent des noms
poétiques comme des griffes ou un sabre
laser a priori rien de trop grave en
tout cas c'était prévu que ça arrive
deuxième souci - bénin le télescope se
prend des micro météorites les micros
météorique c'est normalement moins d'un
gramme et là aussi c'était prévu il
avait été calculé que le miroir devait
s'en prendre en moyenne une par mois
mais sans gravité à part la nécessité de
re bouger un peu le miroir toucher
effectivement c'est ce qui s'est passé 1
il y a eu en six mois cinq impacts de
micro-météorites mais un cela a été
beaucoup plus sérieux que prévu au point
qu'il a légèrement dégradé les
performances optiques du télescope et ce
de façon irrémédiable je vous montre le
graphique que je vous avait affiché pour
dire que les performances étaient
meilleurs que prévu + ébats mieux ses
seins et les parties plus clair en bleu
et vert et bien c'est la performance qui
a été irrémédiablement perdus à cause du
choc de cette micrométéorite
à ce stade on sait pas si c'est juste un
coup de malchance mais en tout cas il
faudra pas que ça se reproduise trop
souvent donc petite inquiétude de ce
côté là d'autant qu'on l'a dit le
télescope il est à 1,5 million de
kilomètres donc une maintenance c'est
hors de question l'un dans le cas de
hubble il y avait eu quatre missions de
maintenance qui ont permis de prolonger
beaucoup sa durée de vie mais là on
était à 500 km de la terre 1 à 1.5
millions de kilomètres donc là le james
webb si on perd on le perd à part ça les
perspectives sont excellentes notamment
concernant la longévité du télescope il
est alimenté par des panneaux solaires
donc pas de limite de batterie et
contrairement à d'autres satellites le
système de refroidissement est en
circuit fermé donc on épuise pas le
fluide réfrigérant a priori le principal
facteur limitant c'est le combustible
alors ils utilisent très peu puisqu'il
est sur une orbite mais il faut quand
même remettre les gaz environ 10
secondes toutes les trois semaines pour
assurer la stabilité de la trajectoire
est aussi compenser le fait que les
photons du soleil le pouce en tapant sur
le bouclier thermique le télescope james
webb a décollé avec 200 litres de
combustible ce qui était censé lui
permettre premièrement de se positionner
correctement après le lancement puis de
tenir entre 5 et 10 ans en
fonctionnement mais le lancement a été
tellement bon et précis qu'il n'a
presque pas taper dans les réserves et
il devrait tenir au moins 20 ans alors
comment ça se passe maintenant que la
mise en service est terminée eh bien les
astronomes du monde entier peuvent
soumettre des propositions pour obtenir
du temps d'observation sur le télescope
il y aura un appel chaque année pour
attribuer les créneaux de l'année
suivante et un comité scientifique qui
tranchera pour le premier cycle
d'observation qui commence près de 1200
projets ont été soumis et seulement 266
retenus pour se partager environ 6000
heures d'observation si ça vous amuse en
théorie n'importe qui peut soumettre un
projet il ya même la documentation du
télescope en ligne d'abord à votre place
je serais pas trop quand même voilà
c'est tout pour ce tour d'horizon rapide
du james webb en réaction à la sortie de
cet article et on voit que c'est quand
même une sacrée aventure scientifique et
technologique qui pour l'instant se
présente plutôt sous les meilleurs
auspices merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo si
ça vous intéresse je mettrai le lien de
l'article scientifique qui est assez
visible abonnez vous activer la cloche
tout ça pour ne rien rater et on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo à bientôt
[Musique]